dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here in a
previous episode we discussed how a
machine learning technique called a
convolutional neural network could paint
in the style of famous artists the key
thought is that we are not interested in
individual details we want to teach the
neural network the high-level concept of
artistic style a convolutional neural
network is a fantastic tool for this
since it does not only recognize image
as well but the deeper we go in the
layers the more high level concepts
neurons will encode therefore the better
idea the algorithm will have of the
artistic style in an earlier example
we've shown that the neurons in the
first hidden layer will create edges as
a combination of the input pixels of the
image the next layer is a combination of
edges that create object parts one layer
deeper a combination of object parts
create object models and this is what
makes convolutional neural networks so
useful in recognizing them in this
follow-up paper the authors use a very
deep nineteen layer convolutional
network that they mix together with
Markov random fields a popular technique
in image and texture synthesis the
resulting algorithm retains the
important structures of the input image
significantly better than the previous
work which is also awesome by the way
failure cases are also reported in the
paper which was a joy to read make sure
to take a look if you're interested we
also have a ton of video resources in
the description box that you can
voraciously consume for more information
there is already a really cool website
where you either wait quite a bit and
get results for free or you pay someone
to compute it and get results almost
immediately if any of you are in the
mood of doing some neural art of
something two minute papers related make
sure to show it to me I'd love to see
that as a criticism I've heard people
saying that the technique takes forever
on an HD image which is absolutely true
but please bear in mind that the most
exciting research is not speeding up
something that runs slowly the most
exciting thing about research is making
something possible that was previously
impossible if the work is worthy of
attention it doesn't matter if it's slow
three follow-up papers later it will
in a matter of seconds in summary the
results are nothing short of amazing I
was full of ecstatically when I first
seen them this is insanity and it's only
been a few months since the initial
algorithm was published I always say
this but we are living amazing times
indeed thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time